salut, je m'appelle Olivia Lanes et bienvenue dans Quantum Computing in practice, voici l'épisode deux : les Quantum
circuits. Nous allons aborder plusieurs sujets dans le cours d'aujourd'hui, mais ce que je veux que tu retiennes, ce sont les trois points suivants : premièrement, ce que sont réellement les
ordinateurs quantiques d'IBM, pour que tu aies au moins une image approximative dans la tête de ce que tu fais quand tu envoies un job à l'un d'eux via le
cloud. Deuxièmement, ce qu'est Qiskit, ce que sont les Primitives, et comment on peut les utiliser pour créer et exécuter des Quantum circuits.
On discutera aussi à haut niveau des différents types de processeurs IBM Quantum disponibles et de ce qui distingue l'un de l'autre. Et troisièmement,
enfin, le workflow typique que l'on suit pour exécuter des expériences à grande échelle. Cela inclut la sélection des meilleures Primitives
pour ton cas d'usage, la correspondance d'un problème à un Quantum circuit, et l'application de la suppression et de la mitigation d'erreurs qui nous permettent
de tirer le maximum de puissance de ces machines. Il y a beaucoup d'informations ici, mais reste avec moi,
car très bientôt on va tout assembler dans le contexte de quelques exemples concrets. Commençons par discuter brièvement des qubits et du véritable matériel Quantum.
En tant qu'expérimentatrice, je peux te promettre que c'est fascinant et que ça aide vraiment à relier les points pour
visualiser ce qui se passe réellement quand des jobs sont envoyés à un ordinateur quantique via le cloud. Les processeurs que
nous allons utiliser sont construits avec des qubits transmon supraconducteurs. Voici à quoi ressemble un petit processeur IBM quantum.
Ces petits carrés ici sont les qubits eux-mêmes, il y en a donc cinq au total sur cette puce. Le transmon
lui-même est un condensateur et il est constitué de deux plaques métalliques connectées en parallèle avec un inducteur non linéaire appelé la
jonction Josephson. Mais pour voir la jonction Josephson, tu dois zoomer encore plus. Elle est créée à partir de deux
couches superposées de métal supraconducteur, et là où les deux pièces se superposent et se touchent se trouve la jonction. Une jonction
Josephson est un élément qui peut être utilisé pour créer un atome artificiel avec plusieurs niveaux d'énergie, et on isole
les deux niveaux d'énergie du bas comme état de notre qubit. Les lignes ondulées ici représentent les résonateurs micro-ondes,
essentiellement des lignes de transmission 2D couplées au qubit. Quand on programme un gate, cela équivaut essentiellement à choisir une
impulsion micro-onde hautement calibrée, et la fréquence, l'amplitude, la forme et la durée spécifiques de ces impulsions font que le
qubit fait des choses spécifiques. Les instructions pour l'impulsion micro-onde vont de ton ordinateur vers le cloud et
sont ensuite lues et interprétées par des électroniques de contrôle à température ambiante qui prennent ces instructions et génèrent physiquement
les impulsions. On les appelle impulsions micro-ondes parce qu'elles s'inscrivent toutes dans la bande de fréquences micro-ondes,
qui est d'environ 1 GHz. Après que les boîtiers de contrôle à température ambiante créent les impulsions, elles voyagent à travers les câbles
dans le réfrigérateur à dilution et finalement jusqu'à notre puce quantique. Le signal entre dans les résonateurs à travers
un fil de liaison sur ces plaquettes, puis il descend la ligne de transmission jusqu'à nos qubits. Je sais que tout cela a peut-être
été un peu technique et ces détails ne sont pas cruciaux à comprendre pour la suite, mais j'espère que tu peux
au moins maintenant visualiser le système physique avec lequel tu vas tous interagir. Alors où sont ces ordinateurs quantiques
concrètement ? Eh bien, IBM possède des dizaines d'ordinateurs quantiques partout dans le monde, et on a récemment mis à niveau notre flotte pour
ne contenir que des processeurs de 100 qubits et plus. Comme je l'ai mentionné dans la leçon précédente, certains d'entre eux sont situés dans un
centre de données IBM Quantum dans l'État de New York. Ces systèmes sont déployés sur le cloud pour l'usage de tous, et certains
sont des systèmes dédiés sur site, complets avec toute l'électronique nécessaire pour les faire fonctionner, qui soutiennent nos partenaires
du réseau IBM Quantum. Maintenant, parlons de Qiskit, qui est le kit de développement logiciel open source d'IBM
conçu pour fonctionner sur des ordinateurs quantiques. Dorénavant, je ferai référence à ceci comme le SDK Qiskit. Il y a aussi l'
écosystème Qiskit, qui est une collection de logiciels, tutoriels et fonctions qui s'appuient sur ou étendent les fonctionnalités principales de Qiskit, ainsi que Qiskit
Runtime, qui est un service d'informatique quantique et un modèle de programmation permettant aux utilisateurs de concevoir et d'exécuter efficacement
leurs charges de travail quantiques en utilisant les Primitives Qiskit. Une Primitive est essentiellement un petit bloc de construction que
tu peux utiliser pour concevoir des circuits plus grands ou un job. Les deux Primitives qui nous importent le plus seront le
sampler et l'estimator, dont on discutera plus en détail sous peu. Si tu n'as pas encore téléchargé et installé le
SDK Qiskit, il n'y a pas de meilleur moment que maintenant. Qiskit 1.0 vient d'être publié et il est plus performant et
stable que jamais. Donc pour ceux qui débutent, vous avez choisi le bon moment. Pour ceux
d'entre vous qui connaissent déjà Qiskit, tu devras télécharger et réinstaller la dernière version. On recommande d'utiliser
pip pour installer Qiskit et Qiskit Runtime et de les exécuter via un notebook Jupyter dans le navigateur web de ton choix. Tu vas donc aussi devoir
installer Jupyter Notebook ou Jupyter Lab au cas où tu ne l'aurais pas encore fait. Ces outils sont tous gratuits et tu
peux les faire fonctionner sur ta propre machine locale sans aucun coût. Assure-toi d'ajouter Qiskit avec les dépendances de l'option de visualisation
pour qu'il fonctionne avec Jupyter et te permette de tracer des graphiques. Tu devras aussi configurer un environnement Python virtuel, et il y a des
instructions sur la façon de le faire sur la page d'installation de Qiskit liée ici. Une fois que tu seras familiarisé avec Qiskit et que tu seras
prêt à exécuter des jobs sur de vrais ordinateurs quantiques, tu devras t'inscrire sur quantum.com et créer un token
API IBM Quantum, et il y a aussi un lien ici pour cela. Pour une démonstration détaillée de la façon de procéder, suis toutes les
instructions sur notre page de documentation comme je l'ai mentionné, ou tu peux regarder la vidéo d'installation Coding with Qiskit ici,
tous deux liés dans la description. On est maintenant presque prêts à commencer à parler des Quantum
circuits. Puisque l'objectif de ce cours est de t'apprendre, à toi le public, comment faire évoluer tes jobs pour être exécutés à une échelle de 100 qubits et plus,
je crois que la façon la plus constructive d'avancer est de d'abord considérer le workflow global que l'on va suivre. Et la façon la plus facile de
comprendre un workflow typique d'informatique quantique est à travers les Qiskit patterns. Les Qiskit patterns sont un cadre conceptuel permettant aux utilisateurs d'exécuter des
charges de travail quantiques en mettant en œuvre certaines étapes avec des outils modulaires. Cela permet que les tâches d'informatique quantique soient réalisées par une
infrastructure de calcul hétérogène puissante. Ces étapes peuvent être réalisées en tant que service et peuvent
intégrer la gestion des ressources, ce qui permet une composabilité transparente des nouvelles capacités au fur et à mesure qu'elles sont développées. Voici
les étapes principales que les utilisateurs expérimentés de Qiskit reconnaîtront probablement déjà. La première étape est le mapping. Cette étape
formalise la façon dont on prend un problème général qui nous intéresse et dont on détermine comment le faire correspondre à un ordinateur quantique
sous la forme d'un circuit. Ensuite, on optimise. Dans cette étape, on utilise le transpiler Qiskit pour router et disposer le
circuit sur un véritable matériel Quantum physique. Cela inclut la traduction des Quantum gates individuels en séquences
WEBVTT
d'opérations qui sont réalisées sur le matériel, ainsi que l'optimisation de la disposition de ces gates. Ensuite, on va
exécuter. Les Primitives du Qiskit Runtime fournissent l'interface au matériel IBM Quantum qui permet au circuit transpilé de s'exécuter.
Cette étape inclut également l'utilisation de techniques de suppression et de mitigation d'erreurs qui peuvent en grande partie être abstraites loin de l'utilisateur. Enfin, on fait le post-traitement.
Dans cette étape, les données provenant du processeur quantique lui-même sont traitées, fournissant à l'utilisateur des résultats utiles sur le problème d'origine. Fondamentalement, cette étape
englobe toute analyse supplémentaire des données qui sont acquises. On est maintenant prêts à discuter de la base des programmes quantiques,
qui sont les Quantum circuits. J'espère que tu es déjà familiarisé avec les Quantum circuits, mais au cas où tu ne l'es pas, tu pourrais d'abord consulter la leçon
trois : Quantum circuits, qui fait partie de "Understanding Quantum Information and Computation", lié ci-dessous. On ne va
faire qu'un bref rappel ici. Un Quantum circuit est un réseau de Quantum gates et de mesures reliés
par des fils qui représentent les qubits. Les Quantum circuits peuvent être lus comme une partition musicale, de gauche à droite, en commençant à
l'instant zéro qui est tout à gauche. Les qubits virtuels, c'est-à-dire les qubits qui n'ont pas encore été assignés à un
qubit physique réel sur un processeur, sont listés en ordre croissant de haut en bas. Une fois qu'on a configuré notre circuit, on peut ajouter
des gates. Les gates à un seul qubit comme ce gate Hadamard ici n'affectent que le qubit sur le fil duquel il est placé. Les gates à plusieurs qubits
comme ce CNOT affectent deux qubits ou plus reliés par le gate. Dans cet exemple, l'état du qubit un change
selon l'état du qubit zéro après. Après que tous les gates ont été appliqués, on peut effectuer des mesures
qui font que les résultats sont écrits sur des registres classiques. Une caractéristique particulièrement importante d'
un circuit est sa profondeur. La profondeur du Quantum circuit est le nombre minimum de couches de Quantum gates exécutées en
parallèle nécessaires pour compléter le calcul défini par le circuit. Pour être clair, les Quantum gates peuvent être exécutés en
parallèle, c'est-à-dire exactement en même temps, lorsqu'ils n'ont aucun qubit en commun. Mais si deux ou plusieurs
gates agissent sur les mêmes qubits, alors on ne peut pas les exécuter en parallèle, on est forcés de les exécuter l'un après l'autre, car les Quantum gates prennent du temps à
implémenter. La profondeur d'un circuit correspond approximativement au temps nécessaire pour que les ordinateurs quantiques exécutent le
circuit. Donc connaître la profondeur d'un circuit est important pour savoir s'il peut être utilisé sur un dispositif particulier ou non. Cela nous dira aussi s'il
a de bonnes chances de produire un résultat précis. Ensuite, passons à la sélection d'un processeur Quantum. IBM
a récemment publié toute une nouvelle flotte de processeurs, tous ayant plus de 100 qubits, et tu peux te connecter sur quantum.com pour voir
auxquels tu as accès. Les processeurs sont tous nommés d'après des oiseaux pour diverses raisons, et les différents logos
représentent différents types de processeurs. Ainsi, par exemple, ceux-ci représentent des processeurs Eagle et cette icône est un
Heron. Le nom des processeurs spécifiques se trouve aussi en haut. Ils sont tous nommés d'après des villes, mais cela
ne signifie pas nécessairement que le processeur est physiquement situé dans cette ville. Ce sont juste des noms. Le nombre de qubits,
l'EPPG et les CLOPS sont aussi des facteurs qui sont tous listés. On va passer en revue chacun d'eux.
Qubits — c'est assez explicite : qubits est simplement le nombre total de qubits disponibles pour l'utilisation sur ce seul processeur Quantum ou
QPU. EPPG signifie errors per layered gate, qui mesure l'erreur de processus de gate moyen dans une chaîne en couches de
100 qubits. En gros, tu veux que ce soit le plus petit possible. CLOPS signifie circuit layer operations per second et
mesure combien de couches d'un Quantum volume circuit, qui est un circuit virtuel, un QPU peut exécuter par unité de temps.
Plus le nombre est élevé, plus vite on peut calculer. C'est l'équivalent de ce que signifient les FLOPS en calcul classique. Ces
différentes métriques peuvent être plus ou moins importantes selon le domaine d'application spécifique qui t'intéresse. Ensuite, discutons à haut niveau
du mapping vers les Quantum circuits. La première étape est l'étape de mapping qui répond essentiellement à la question : comment
est-ce que je traduis mon problème en un Quantum circuit qui peut être exécuté sur du matériel Quantum ? Il n'y a aucun doute là-dessus,
le mapping est un problème difficile et c'est un domaine de recherche actif. Parfois, juste être capable de prendre un problème computationnel
et de trouver une séquence de Quantum gates qui aide à le résoudre est la partie la plus difficile. Il n'existe pas de méthode infaillible
qui garantit le succès, mais il existe des lignes directrices recommandées et des exemples de problèmes qu'on sait déjà comment
mapper. La première directive est de laisser les ordinateurs classiques faire le travail qu'ils font mieux eux-mêmes. Les tests
qui sont faciles pour les ordinateurs classiques ne bénéficieront probablement pas d'un ordinateur quantique. Les ordinateurs quantiques sont pour les problèmes classiquement difficiles.
Bien sûr, si c'est ta toute première fois avec Qiskit ou un ordinateur quantique, ne t'inquiète pas de trouver un problème computationnellement complexe. Décompose-le
en problèmes plus petits que tu peux apprendre à résoudre avant de te lancer directement dans un projet à l'échelle utilitaire. Ensuite, traduis les
résultats pour ton problème que tu veux mesurer ou comprendre en un problème de valeur d'espérance ou un problème d'échantillonnage.
Pour la plupart des types de problèmes, cela correspond essentiellement au calcul d'une fonction de coût. Une fonction de coût est une
fonction spécifique au problème qui définit l'objectif du problème comme quelque chose à minimiser ou maximiser, et elles peuvent être
utilisées pour voir à quel point un état ou une solution d'essai se comporte par rapport à cet objectif.
Cette notion peut s'appliquer à diverses applications en chimie, apprentissage automatique, finance, optimisation, etc.
Garde aussi à l'esprit que le matériel que tu vas utiliser a une topologie spécifique. Certains qubits ne sont pas connectés,
certains le sont, et tu devras finalement faire correspondre ton problème à un circuit qui représente cela. Les processeurs IBM Quantum
utilisent ce qu'on appelle une topologie heavy hex qui équivaut essentiellement à des connexions de qubits dans un réseau hexagonal, dont
on parlera plus en détail dans le cours. Pour l'instant, la chose la plus importante à garder à l'esprit est que cette étape nécessite de
la pratique. Tu dois bien comprendre non seulement ton problème, mais aussi les
capacités du matériel Quantum, et on va passer à travers un exemple et un cas d'utilisation spécifiques plus tard pour voir comment ceux-ci peuvent être au mieux
équilibrés. Maintenant, discutons de la façon d'optimiser un circuit pour le matériel qu'on a sélectionné. L'objectif global de l'
étape d'optimisation est de faire correspondre tous les qubits virtuels de notre circuit à de vrais qubits réels quelque part sur la
topologie du processeur. Le but du jeu est de réduire les erreurs autant que possible. Pour ce faire, on doit d'abord
router et disposer notre circuit efficacement. La première chose à garder à l'esprit est que tous les qubits ne sont pas connectés,
comme je l'ai déjà dit, certains sont en fait loin les uns des autres sur la puce. On doit donc réduire ou éliminer les interactions à longue distance
dans la mesure du possible. Tu peux appliquer une séquence de swap gates entre des qubits voisins pour déplacer les informations de qubit,
mais les swap gates sont coûteux et sujets aux erreurs, il peut donc y avoir de meilleures façons de procéder. Ensuite, la disposition
WEBVTT
et le routage sont des processus itératifs qui assignent un qubit virtuel de ton circuit au qubit physique sur le
matériel. Tu peux le faire à la main, mais il y a aussi des outils dans Qiskit qui peuvent faire des recommandations pour la disposition physique du
qubit basées sur des taux d'erreur approximatifs. Ensuite, on peut composer des séquences de gates à un seul qubit agissant sur le même qubit
en des gates uniques, et on peut aussi parfois se débarrasser de gates inutiles ou de combinaisons de gates. Par exemple,
certaines combinaisons de gates peuvent être réduites à des combinaisons plus simples, et parfois des combinaisons de gates
équivalent même à un simple opérateur identité, on peut donc simplement les éliminer. Tu peux faire cela automatiquement en utilisant le
transpiler Qiskit, ou tu peux le faire manuellement gate par gate si tu as une bonne raison de le faire et que tu veux
plus de contrôle. Une fois qu'on a amélioré la disposition du circuit, le routage et les comptes de gates, soit à la main ou en utilisant le transpiler Qiskit, on
veut généralement visualiser notre circuit pour s'assurer que le timing de tous les gates est logique. Il y a un argument qu'on peut signaler dans le transpiler pour
visualiser la timeline de ton circuit et s'assurer que tout est aligné comme tu t'y attendrais. Maintenant, parlons de la
suppression d'erreurs. La suppression d'erreurs fait référence à diverses techniques qui transforment un circuit lors de la compilation pour minimiser les erreurs.
C'est différent de la mitigation d'erreurs qui se déroule après que le circuit a déjà été exécuté, et on y viendra sous peu. Les deux formes les plus courantes de
suppression d'erreurs dont on tire parti sont le découplage dynamique et le twirling de Pauli. Il va y avoir quelques
détails techniques ici, mais tu peux toujours y revenir plus tard. Donc, premièrement, le découplage dynamique est utilisé pour
annuler efficacement une partie du bruit affectant le qubit en appliquant une série de gates qui ensemble s'élèvent à l'
opération d'identité, comme les séquences XX, et dont l'effet net est d'annuler approximativement les canaux de bruit affectant
le qubit. Le twirling de Pauli est un moyen d'insérer des gates aléatoires pour simplifier le bruit moyen. Le caractère aléatoire aide à
empêcher les effets des différentes erreurs de s'accumuler aussi vite et rend aussi le bruit plus facile à caractériser.
Cette méthode constitue également la base d'une technique de mitigation d'erreurs et on va en discuter plus tard.
Encore une fois, il y a beaucoup d'informations ici et ne t'inquiète pas si tout ne rentre pas immédiatement. Heureusement, beaucoup de cela peut être fait automatiquement en utilisant le
transpiler Qiskit. La transpilation peut être délicate, mais la transpilation est une étape tellement cruciale pour atteindre l'utilité à grande échelle
qu'elle nécessite beaucoup d'essais et d'erreurs pour être maîtrisée et obtenir les meilleurs résultats. Maintenant, je veux prendre une brève
parenthèse pour discuter du transpiler Qiskit et de ses capacités un peu plus. Je le ferai à un niveau très élevé et on entrera dans les détails et verra
quelques exemples plus loin. En général, la transpilation est le processus de réécriture d'un circuit d'entrée donné pour correspondre à
la topologie et au dispositif Quantum spécifique, et d'optimiser le circuit pour l'exécution et la résilience contre le bruit. Elle
réécrit aussi un circuit donné dans les gates de base de ce processeur Quantum spécifique que tu as sélectionné pour utilisation. Qiskit a quatre
pipelines de transpilation intégrés, et à moins que tu sois déjà familiarisé avec l'optimisation de Quantum circuit, je recommande vraiment d'utiliser l'un de ces
pipelines intégrés. Par défaut, le transpiler inclut ces six étapes : initialisation,
disposition, routage, traduction, optimisation et planification. L'initialisation fait référence à
tout passage initial nécessaire avant qu'on commence à intégrer le circuit sur le backend. Cela implique généralement
de déplier les instructions personnalisées et de convertir le circuit en gates à un et deux qubits uniquement. L'étape de disposition applique
un mapping de disposition des qubits virtuels du circuit aux qubits physiques sur un backend. Le routage s'exécute après qu'une disposition a été
appliquée et injecte des gates tels que les swap gates dans le circuit original pour le rendre compatible avec la
connectivité du backend. La quatrième étape est la traduction. Dans cette étape, les gates du circuit sont traduits vers la cible
du jeu de base du backend. Ensuite vient l'optimisation. Cette étape exécute la boucle d'optimisation principale
de manière répétée jusqu'à ce qu'une condition, comme atteindre une certaine profondeur cible, soit satisfaite. On a quatre niveaux d'optimisation différents
parmi lesquels on peut choisir. En dernier vient la planification. Cette étape est destinée à tout passage de planification conscient du matériel. À un
niveau élevé, la planification peut être pensée comme l'insertion de délais dans le circuit pour tenir compte de tout temps d'inactivité sur les qubits
entre l'exécution des instructions. Donc comme je l'ai dit, il y a quatre niveaux d'optimisation allant de 0 à 3, où les
niveaux d'optimisation plus élevés prennent plus de temps et d'effort computationnel, mais tu pourrais te retrouver avec un meilleur circuit.
Le niveau d'optimisation zéro est destiné aux expériences de caractérisation de dispositif et, en tant que tel, ne fait que correspondre le circuit d'entrée aux
contraintes du backend cible. Il n'effectue aucune optimisation. Le niveau d'optimisation trois
consacre le plus d'efforts à l'optimisation du circuit. Cependant, comme beaucoup des techniques d'optimisation dans le
transpiler sont basées sur des heuristiques, dépenser plus d'efforts computationnels n'entraîne pas toujours une amélioration
de la qualité du circuit de sortie. Si cela t'intéresse davantage, consulte les pages du transpiler dans la documentation
de Qiskit liée ci-dessous. On est maintenant prêts à discuter de l'exécution réelle d'un Quantum circuit.
Les Primitives du Qiskit Runtime fournissent une interface au matériel IBM Quantum et elles abstraient aussi la
suppression et la mitigation d'erreurs pour l'utilisateur. La Primitive sampler retourne la distribution de quasi-probabilité ou les comptages
représentant la vraisemblance de mesurer certaines chaînes de bits, zéros et uns. La Primitive estimator retourne les valeurs d'espérance
d'observables correspondant à des grandeurs physiques. Donc avec un peu plus de détail, le sampler exécute le circuit
plusieurs fois sur un dispositif Quantum, effectuant des mesures à chaque exécution et construisant la distribution de probabilité
à partir de la récupération de ces chaînes de bits. Plus d'exécutions ou de shots on effectue, plus les résultats seront précis,
mais cela nécessite plus de temps et les ressources Quantum requises pour l'exécuter. Plus précisément, il calcule la
probabilité d'obtenir chaque état de base standard possible en mesurant l'état préparé par le circuit. L'
estimator de Qiskit utilise un processus algébrique complexe pour estimer la valeur d'espérance sur un vrai dispositif Quantum en
décomposant l'observable en une combinaison d'autres observables qui ont des bases propres connues et en les exécutant. Sous
le capot des Primitives se trouvent les techniques appelées mitigation d'erreurs. La mitigation d'erreurs est un terme générique pour tout cela et
fait essentiellement référence aux techniques qui nous permettent de réduire les erreurs du circuit en modélisant le bruit du dispositif au moment de l'
exécution. Cela entraîne généralement une surcharge de pré-traitement Quantum liée à l'entraînement du modèle et une surcharge de
post-traitement classique pour atténuer les erreurs dans les résultats bruts en utilisant un modèle généré. Mais en échange de cette
surcharge, on est capables d'obtenir des résultats beaucoup plus précis. Il y a plusieurs techniques qu'on peut mettre en œuvre pour
WEBVTT
la mitigation d'erreurs et on va en passer trois en revue plus en détail. Sois conscient cependant que c'est un domaine de
recherche active, donc de nouvelles techniques seront probablement inventées et les plus anciennes continueront à être améliorées. Le
niveau de résilience augmente le coût, c'est-à-dire le temps qu'il faut pour exécuter ton job. On a déjà dit qu'au
niveau de résilience zéro, le transpiler ne fait vraiment rien à ton circuit. Mais à partir du niveau de résilience un, il introduit une méthode appelée twirled
readout error extinction, ou T-Rex en abrégé. Le twirled readout error extinction utilise le twirling de Pauli pour
atténuer le bruit, ce qu'on a déjà abordé. C'est une technique très générale et efficace qui,
intuitivement, rend le bruit moins irrégulier et plus facile à gérer. À partir du niveau de résilience deux, on
introduit l'extrapolation à bruit zéro, ou ZNE en abrégé. C'est une technique populaire avec laquelle on a récemment eu beaucoup
de succès. L'idée derrière la ZNE peut être un peu surprenante : on ajoute en fait du bruit supplémentaire
par-dessus ce qui est déjà là. Mais ce que cela fait, c'est qu'il nous permet d'extrapoler dans la direction inverse pour
prédire à quoi ressembleraient les résultats s'il y avait moins de bruit. Cela peut être fait de plusieurs façons spécifiques. Par exemple, on peut
étirer les gates pour les rendre plus longs et donc plus susceptibles aux erreurs, ou on peut exécuter plus de gates qui finissent
par aboutir à une opération d'identité, de sorte que le circuit ne change pas fonctionnellement mais qu'on échantillonne délibérément plus de
bruit. Tu dois cependant le faire pour chaque circuit et chaque valeur d'espérance que tu veux suivre, donc tu
peux voir comment cela peut finir par être très coûteux en termes de temps requis. Un type spécifique de ZNE est appelé
amplification d'erreur probabiliste, ou PEA en abrégé. Une fois qu'on a appris un modèle de bruit pour un gate, la PEA fonctionne en échantillonnant
des erreurs à partir de ce modèle de bruit et en les injectant délibérément dans le circuit. Comme je l'ai mentionné, beaucoup de nouvelles
techniques continuent à être développées et seront avec espoir mises en œuvre au fur et à mesure que de plus en plus voient le jour. Il n'y a qu'une dernière forme de
mitigation d'erreurs que je veux aborder, appelée annulation d'erreur probabiliste. Au lieu d'être au troisième niveau de résilience,
la PEC est une capacité spéciale qu'on doit activer manuellement dans Qiskit, car les ressources computationnelles
nécessaires ne s'adaptent pas très bien par rapport aux autres techniques de mitigation d'erreurs qu'on a discutées. Tu
commences par apprendre le bruit qui affecte ton circuit en exécutant des circuits d'apprentissage du bruit ou de caractérisation du bruit
pour chaque couche unique de deux qubit gates qui sont dans ton circuit. Ces résultats te permettent de décrire le bruit
en termes d'opérateurs de Pauli. Une fois que tu connais ces termes de bruit, tu peux modifier tes circuits pour qu'ils
aient effectivement les PEC opposées intégrées pour annuler ces canaux de bruit. D'une certaine façon, ce processus est
similaire à celui des casques à réduction de bruit. Cependant, cette façon d'annuler le bruit est très coûteuse, avec un temps d'
exécution qui croît exponentiellement vite en fonction du nombre de gates. Ce n'est donc peut-être pas le meilleur choix pour un très grand circuit. On a
maintenant atteint l'étape finale : le post-traitement. Au final, si tu as bien travaillé et employé des techniques de mitigation d'erreurs appropriées,
tu pourrais voir ta réponse finale évoluer, comme dans cette figure ici. Une distribution non atténuée
montrée en violet est assez loin de la vraie valeur attendue montrée ici par cette ligne. Cependant, une fois qu'on applique notre mitigation d'erreurs,
on obtient une distribution atténuée montrée ici en bleu qui culmine bien plus près de la vraie valeur. Maintenant,
tout cela a un coût, et on peut voir ici que la variance ou la largeur de la distribution est augmentée, ce qui n'est
généralement pas ce qu'on veut, mais tout a un coût. Heureusement, on peut compenser cela en exécutant plus de
shots, ce qui fait que la distribution se rétrécit à un niveau d'incertitude acceptable. Voilà pour cette
leçon. Pour la prochaine fois, on va prendre toutes ces étapes, les assembler et travailler à travers un exemple
d'application concrète. Il y a quelques choses que je peux te recommander de faire d'ici là. Si tu ne l'as pas encore fait,
assure-toi de télécharger et de configurer Qiskit 1.0. Tu peux aussi consulter la leçon associée à ce chapitre et
l'épisode précédent sur la plateforme IBM Quantum Learning, et enfin, si tu as un quelconque intérêt à approfondir et
à en apprendre davantage sur les techniques de mitigation d'erreurs, consulte l'une des nombreuses sources que j'ai liées ci-dessous. En attendant, à la prochaine fois !
[Musique]